I wrote this this book mainly to to
think about how we ought to be in as an
unashamed made lifelong member of the
Labour Party that is that's where I'm
coming from how we ought to be able to
think about the future and start
preparing for the era that's coming and
part of that I thought was a critique of
where we are now and how we've managed
to evolve our society in a context that
is really about what I call market
fundamentalism in the book the unwritten
market fundamentalist rules and I'll
talk about them in a minute I wanted to
talk today about a more positive view of
where I think we should be going as
Democratic socialists and I'm
unashamedly a Democratic Socialist I'm
not a communist and I'm not a vanguard
isten I'm not too Leninist and I'm not
any of those things I don't believe that
you can develop a society that's
democratic and socialist without the
consent of people in it or out with a
democratic system and I think that there
are five main values which when I
thought about what socialism meant to me
as a lifelong member of the Labour Party
we would have to try to apply when we
were thinking about what kind of society
want to create in the 21st century
rather than resting on the laurels of
the society we created in the 19th or
the 20th and those values in no
particular order are equality democracy
Liberty cooperation and internationalism
and I think that everything that I tried
to say in the book needs to be
encompassed in making those values real
for everybody in our society so what I
thought it would be
interesting to do is just for me to talk
a little bit about some of the things I
think we need to change and then say a
few words about areas where that change
might manifest itself just to give you
an idea of what's in my mind about how
we shape the development of our of our
society so I think the first thing to
say is that you have to have I mentioned
it this morning I said be a citizen of
nowhere you have to have a view from
nowhere
in other words you have to get away from
what the essential view that we've had
since the triumph of Thatcherism
happened 40 years ago of the motivations
of individuals in society and that is
that somehow we are all in it to
maximize our own advantage and our own
wealth and if as individuals we do that
then society will miraculously
automatically be the best it can i
profoundly disagree with that kind of
analysis and I actually think that human
beings actually set themselves in a much
more social context than that they set
themselves in a much more collectivist
context than that because they actually
do have what Thomas Nagel the
rationalist philosopher called a view
from nowhere and that is they have the
morality and ethics such that they have
an objective view of other people's
circumstances and the position they're
in so they're not pursuing only we
aren't pursuing our own satisfaction and
utility constantly with no regard to
anyone else actually in varying degrees
we have a lot of regard for other people
and if we accept that as a principle
from which we organize society
it creates an ethical and compassionate
view which I think starts to animate
some of the values that I was talking
about earlier so unlike Teresa May I
don't believe that if you're not a
citizen of somewhere you're a citizen of
nowhere and somehow that's a bad thing
I also think by the way that having that
moral view will become increasingly
important as the world struggles with
issues like climate change and the
interact there interrelatedness of our
globe which is getting more and more
into relate to rather than less and less
so without that view I think it's very
difficult to really assert yourself as a
society to do anything useful for your
own society or anyone else and so that's
the first thing I think that there are
some things that need to change at a
high level about our politics to make
them different so I just want to use a
few examples firstly I would say the
empowerment of women and in the book I
call that completing the Enlightenment
because I kind of agree with Mary
Wollstonecraft and she thought when the
Enlightenment ideas were developed that
it included women that the French
Revolution when it talked about
fraternity a gala tea all of that that
women were included only to be horrified
to find out that Talleyrand and all the
French revolutionaries only wanted all
of that for men which is why she wrote a
vindication of the rights of women to
begin with and I think it's about time
the feminism and 51% of the population
got to have their fair and equal go at
helping to run the world so that's the
first thing I think that would actually
transform a lot of the way that things
are done and when I talk about women as
well I'm going to include those other
minorities not majorities which are all
avulsed tended to be excluded from power
so people who are discriminated against
people with disabilities all of the
range of discriminations that are
protected in law need to be brought into
our political system so that we can hear
their voices and accommodate to their
needs wants and and desires so that's
number one
I
think number two we need to get away
from the narrow utilitarian view of
politics which has come about as a
result of our marketized approach to
economics and society and that is
somehow that politics is a choice of
brands that you can choose one or the
other that you have a retail view of
politics --is who's got the best adverts
who can persuade you to bright by blue
trainers or red trainers and then you
can pick one or the other but you've all
always got to have trainers and nothing
really changes because the trainers are
provided by particular people and and
companies that you have no effect on I
don't think that's a reasonable way of
politics I've always said about politics
if you don't do politics you get it done
to you and so a lot of the people that
are excluded from power that are
excluded from positions of influence
don't feel that politics is for them and
there's a lot of there there are the
people that are the vested interests
that want to keep it that way and you
actually get real change and development
in society when those people who don't
do politics stop thinking it's a
spectator sport and start thinking you
know what I'm not cheering on my side
from the stands I ought to be on the
pitch and if you're on the pitch and you
can persuade people to get involved in
politics in that way you can have major
transformation of the sort that I don't
think many of us have likely to have
experienced in our lifetimes to date so
let's get rid of the technocratic
utilitarian retail view of politics and
that opens up a Vista of possibilities
for proper organization of debate and
how we actually change our politics for
the good I think also it's important
that we think about a complete change in
the way that we regard economics
as a Democratic Socialist I think the
way we run our economy the labor market
we have the kind of structures we have
in our society a really important part
of whether we can empower people that's
to help people who are from the working
class get on to ensure that everyone has
the right to reach their full potential
in life and also contribute to the
common good that we can develop in our
society so it's not about individual
striving only it is about how we can all
try to contribute to the common good and
so I think when we look at the way that
economics works we also see that very
narrow utilitarian neoclassical approach
if I could call it that Homo economicus
I think the phrase is and it is a homo a
man what I mean when I say that
obviously an economic man and the
utilitarian implications of how that
works have narrowed our politics and the
possibilities of change for a very very
long time they are profit maximizing
utility maximizing always fighting
everyone else for their bit of the pie
there's no real attempt to create a
system that is much more holistic for
more debates talks and interviews
subscribe today to the Institute's of
Arts and ideas at IAI TV
you